des gens raconte qu'il est nul à chier
sur les jeux vidéo jeux de stratégie
jeux de combat fps et ps il est nul à
chier partout mais aujourd'hui ils
décident de vous jouer ni maître gims au
ukulélé de vous prouver qu'il n'est pas
si nul à chier il va faire sur plérin
cno bad brains vous souvenez avions en
effet sur la chose et d'un avec mika
l'enquêté racing gotha l'escouade de
luxe est bien le but était d'être le
dernier en vie dans ce jeu c'est pareil
le but c'est d'être le dernier en vie on
va être sans projeter sur une main il
faut s'armer s'équiper à base de gilet
pare-balles de casques de webphones et
être le dernier avis c'est parti on peut
atterrir dans plusieurs villes comme
c'est noté ici et là on va atterrir à
iasnaïa poliana qui est une petite ville
suisse très mignonne c'est entièrement
faux mais je vous aime quand même à me
suis ce que vous êtes prêt on la voit
ces partis direction bastian a poliana
vous en faites pas et avec le guide sur
votre guide dans cette [ __ ] de vidéo
vous allez voir on va casser des culots
de but ça va être de trouver une arme le
plus vite possible et de regarder
combien de gens autour de nous attend il
y en a un qui est là ok je leur père
comme ça je pourrais le défoncer on
atterrit on atterrit 0 c'est parti
let's go claque qu'est ce qu'on a ici au
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] c'est la folie à cannes
hop hop hop là le but c'est de mettre
son casque à fond pour entendre les
ennemis arrivent et avec casque level 2
mais qu'on se met bien je vous jure
qu'on se met bien je me suis rarement vu
aussi bien le regard on agit les deux
polices avait mais que demande le peuple
on oublie un fusil à pompe les amis je
suis fier vous annoncer qu'on se met mes
gars bien et comment a tout de suite
cherché la baston sur le mec on a vu
atterrir plus tôt il va est en état de
choc
à pita je dois dire sa peur que lui
c'est ce mur et je sais qu'il ya un mec
pas loin je peux sentir son odeur de
fauves sur partout dans les villes dans
les campagnes terme et ne voit personne
les amis on se fait boycott quoi on a
zéro pote hockey plan b
j'ai peur pour voir la boisson
énergisante pour se soigner de salon
mais refait [ __ ] j'ai pas vu d'où il
m'a tiré de ce conte [ __ ] suivait
guide ne paniquez pas la panique est un
sentiment nul alors débarrassez vous en
je suis très fier alors le blâme jeu
explique c'est qu'il ya un champ de
force qui va sera menée dans pas
longtemps et il faudra fuir ce champ de
force g ralement pour aller vers le
milieu du cercle ce match derby pas de
panique pas que manager ok vous l'avez
vu on prend en charge tel un cyborg je
parle pas de nec feu ok alors on va le
tuer sur d'une expo car nous sommes un
solent ne paniquez pas et là vous l'avez
vu il est juste là et à la chaufferie
nos potes c'est bon ça c'est fait y'en a
un autre c mais brut par mois ou ces
personnes n'entrave une visite entre son
guide et ses abonnés vous avez compris
je le dis haut et fort en j'en tremble
maintenant cette mise au point est fait
regardons la map donc comme on peut le
voir je suis dans le cercle bleu et non
dans le cercle blanc ce qui veut dire
que quand le championnat sera branché
sur est dans la merde faut qu'on se bat
on ya laissé par la droite messieurs
dames on longe la route principale
alors ne jamais marcher sur les grands
doutes comme ça mais un surnom pas que
vous allez vous faire écraser vous et
vous faire chasser comme le mec là bas
où le voyez on l'a vu on va le trac et à
ça c'est les touristes qui ont plus de
thunes que vous à votre droite vous
pouvez apercevoir des pauvres et qui ont
un guide carrément qui pilote un avion -
non moi ça y'a pas il est quelque part
je ne vois pas ça c'est très dangereux
ok la prochaine zone a été indiquée elle
est à quelques mètres seulement on va
traverser rose hok oo
hop hop hop a alors soit un mec attiré
pas loin soit il joue avec du bison 4
plus d'un jeu je vais pas vous mentir
les gens adorent camper à une [ __ ] de
fenêtres mais le cas est en train de se
raser les boules dans la maison où c'est
le bruit d'un véhicule domec et le
batteur qui a voulu me tirer dessus là
mais bien un mec dans la maison je vous
jure ya un mec dans cette maison j'ai
entendu il entendait tout en élevant à
la plainte avec son gros qu'un 88 2 bat
là c'est un sniper et my one shot et la
fin du guide bah voilà le mec il mettait
une fenêtre comme ça il attendait qu'un
qu'on s'arrête pour parler à sa
communauté parce qu'il aime ça que
menotté boyer et lui il aime pas du coup
il a fait quoi pourquoi je fais ce geste
italien on sait pas non plus aux plats
dans ma tête voilà donc tout ce qu'il
faut lozeau twitch maghrébins golan
paulo bon les amis on va atterrir ici
approaching qui bien sûr petite ville de
la lorraine
on apprécie la lorraine dédicace aux
londoniens ok ce parti est là faut juste
très prudent avec maison dié mon gars de
quazar mais aucun cas ce qu on est bien
on est bien on est bien
c'est pas loin ça ok y'a un mec est dans
la maison les américains les ont paniqué
pas paniqué par il arrive
ok ya bel et bien mais qu'il envoyait
une green a tenté mais bien de quoi tu
as peur gamin vient je peux prendre part
à la visite sans problème il suffit de
payer ton ticket comme tous ces gens
allez tu payes voilà il est là hiver et
voilà on n'a pas plu à fallait payer
fallait payer terre ifri du de quoi mais
cac 40 hors bon ça c'est fait ok on a un
ponte maintenant on est bien les amis
vous l'avez vu vous le voyez en bas
certes il a bougé les loups il est où il
est passé ou s'il s'est pas vu ça mais
qu'il est quand qu est ce que tu avais
je prends en touche pour tout ce que tu
as demain tout ce que tu es un vrai show
le scar elle est apparemment la
meilleure arme du jeu de ce que j'ai vu
du coup nous avait super bien parce
qu'il en avait un secours
[Applaudissements]
ce qui est en train de rien est-ce que
ça se voit à cause de ce geste avec
cette langue oui ans 15 kg zem tirer
dessus qu'il se vante emballé coup j'ai
tout mon temps je vais attendent ici
avec ces gens sagement avant de
reprendre la visite comme il se doit ou
êtes-vous à dollar s'est jamais grenade
comme le guide au [ __ ] c'est
désastreux ce que j'ai fait on est dans
la zone toujours avec les autres gens on
est bien au final on est bien moi je
pense qu'on devrait juste le temps de
faire le point sur notre vie sur ces
deux dernières années tranquillement
ensemble bien sûr téphany commence noter
côté robert vont tous merci à tous de
prendre le temps de m'écouter ça me fait
super plaisir aux tags altman et attend
rien tu piaget là où vous l'avez vu ben
oui un peu plus noir aux locaux le mec
on l'a cassée en deux le pauvre on est
dégoûté il s'est désabonné sous les
autres maintenant
merde je suis en pleine zone rouge faut
que je me casse c'est bon parce que si
vous saviez pas en gros dés foyenne zone
rouge qui apparaît il ya des avions qui
bombardent de dents voilà il faut se
mettre dans un bâtiment pour être à
l'abri alors les amis maintenant que ça
c'est un petit peu calmé on va pouvoir
reprendre faisait tranquillement là bas
c'est tout simplement la cathédrale de
lorraine sur marne bien sûr justice est
un tag dégueulasse il ya toutes les
régions ces messieurs département
dégueulasse ah mais oui c'est la journée
portes ouvertes de la cathédrale de
lorraine sur marne attendez on va y
aller on entend les gens non mais calme
toi aussi
on va échapper la voiture qu'à la barre
ça peut être nous est très utile pour
est dans ses petits bâtiments là bas un
petit peu isolé bien sûr prenez les
bosses pour le spectacle ça impressionne
vos adversaires et ne sont plus aptes à
vont viser correctement après cela alors
là ce qu'il faudrait c'est trouver une
lunette x 4 ou x bit et des bruits
dégage tu ne mentiras fils de [ __ ]
voilà [ __ ] ces fameux pic à mano avec
médias et l'autre il avance la peur vous
le voyez ou pas est-ce que vous le voyez
cette petite raclures il n'attend que ça
[Applaudissements]
les bals traversent les murs ont des
boutons
nous voilà maintenant dans l'avion
1 2 3 4 ils sont quatre mais il n'en
restera qu'un
gilet pare-balles tchèque casque tchèque
fusil d'assaut pour la paix encore
ennemi tchèque
taux
ok routes barrées terme et on n'a rien
yes
[Applaudissements]
y ait la chance ne sourit jamais on va
pas la décevoir
rigaux
et wat mêlée où ce campeur là
vous l'avez vu
tu veux me tuer cet accès aux mondieux 1
qu'elle obtienne honte pour tous les
guides de france vont les amis la visite
est terminée n'hésitez pas allez
messieurs vous a plu [ __ ] je me suis
éclaté je suis dommage parce qu'on avait
fait des trombones gamme au début et là
sur la fin j'ai intéressé avait avec des
peu rodé j'en faisais pas trop se
montrer qu'ils match je suis triste de
gaston rigolo comme je dis aimez la
vidéo si elle vous a plu et aussi je
prendrai en compte pour autant faire une
deuxième pourquoi pas vous vraiment ça
me fait trop marrer ce jeu il est
vraiment allé à bientôt dans une
prochaine vidéo merci d'avoir gardé
comme on dit
[Musique]